In 1984, French philosopher Jacques Derrida
defined nuclear war as a "fabulously textual"
reality about which "one can only talk and
write about" because "it has not yet, and,
in a sense cannot ever take place, since if
it did, there would be no place remaining."
Clear and concise.
In the common imagination, but also in practice,
there is only one way to attempt to escape
the disastrous effects of a nuclear detonation:
holing up in a fallout shelter.
A bunker is nothing more than an underground
shelter that, in a wartime context, is exploited
to protect armaments, resources, and military
personnel.
This was true, at least, until August 1945,
when the world verified the existence of a
weapon capable of exterminating the human
race: the atomic bomb.
According to American professor David L. Pike,
it was precisely the Cold War, with which
the danger of a global nuclear holocaust was
associated, that gave rise to the so-called
bunker fantasy, that is, the widespread belief
that bomb shelters are necessary for the safety
of mankind.
Bunker fantasy exorcises death, and generates
hope even towards a future of death and destruction.
After all, this is precisely the function
of the post-apocalyptic genre, well represented
by video games such as Fallout.
Well, someone has taken this concept literally.
We are talking about Switzerland, the most
bunkered country in the world.
With its about 370.000 private fallout shelters,
plus 9.000 public ones intended for those
who don’t have the budget to install them
in their own homes, on paper Switzerland is
able to protect as many as 9 million people
from radiation, or more than 100% of its entire
population.
Impressive, huh?
But how did it happen?
It all starts with a pre-Cold War bunker fantasy.
We are at the beginning of the Second World
War.
France has been defeated by the Third Reich,
which towers in the north and has annexed
Austria.
To the south, on the other hand, is fascist
Italy.
Although Switzerland declared neutrality,
rising border tensions prompted the authorities
to prepare for a fight.
On July 25, 1940, General Henri Guisan suggested
making the Alps, Switzerland's natural barrier,
the largest fortress in Europe.
The plan is as follows: abandon the northern
and southern borders, as well as the center
of the country, to allow the army to hole
up in a network of military shelters built
into the rocks.
In fact, the so-called National Redoubt strategy,
also known as Schweizer Reduit or Réduit
national, had been nagging at the minds of
the Swiss government since the 1880s, and
World War II only served as a fuse for the
project to be carried out.
This Alpine fortification consisted of three
main bastions, the Gotthard, Saint-Maurice
and Sargans complexes, overseeing 70 other
mountain citadels and 10,000 bunkers capable
of housing hundreds of men each, protected
by armored doors and stocked with food, weapons
and ammunition.
According to an estimate reported by the New
York Times in 1999, the Redoubt cost Switzerland
$10 billion.
Judged in retrospect, this strategy would
be considered, yes, a huge deterrent designed
to discourage Axis forces from invading the
Alps, but also an absurd idea.
In fact, "reducing" the country, in the view
of the Swiss generals, meant sacrificing the
central plains where the vast majority of
the population lived.
In short, it was a calculation based on the
survival of the armed forces alone.
Yet the obsession of the fortress between
the Alps would survive in a different form
after the Second World War.
In the presence of a far more deadly threat
than air raids and tank advances, namely the
atomic bomb, the Swiss public became increasingly
aware of the need to protect itself from all-out
war.
It wasn’t only the Iron Curtain that haunted
Swiss military strategists, but the very real
risk that the Cold War could soon...heat up.
As early as the Korean War of 1950-1953, the
Swiss Federal Council, or the seven-member
directorate that performs the functions of
both government and head of state, ruled that
every newly constructed building should be
equipped with an air raid shelter.
Then, in 1956, the Suez crisis prompted the
Federal Council to raise civil defense to
the status of a constitutional right and the
ultimate responsibility of state authorities.
That said, defense finds constitutional protection
in Article 2, in the part that states that
"the Confederation [...] safeguards [...] the
security of the country."
But two additional historical contingencies
would prompt the Swiss government to apply
drastic measures in preparation for a global
conflict that seemed inevitable at the time:
the building of the Berlin Wall in 1961 and
the Cuban Missile Crisis in October 1962.
Not surprisingly, also in 1962, the Swiss
parliament created a Federal Office for Civil
Protection, abbreviated to FOCP, still in
existence today, whose tasks are to inform
and alert citizens in case of danger, and
coordinate possible rescue operations.
In October 1963, by unanimous vote of both
houses of parliament, the Federal Act on Civil
Defense Construction was passed.
The latter provided for the installation of
public fallout bunkers in every settlements
with more than 1.000 inhabitants.
And not only that.
Under Article 46, all property owners were
to construct and equip their own bomb shelter.
This was a rather ambitious provision, but
it was dictated by well-established ideological
reasons.
According to historian Silvia Berger Ziauddin,
Geistige Landesverteidigung, that is the "national
intellectual defense," implied that bunkers
had to protect all fundamental Swiss values:
federalism, freedom, independence and neutrality.
At the same time, however, it was the latter
that was sacrificed.
Although Switzerland never became a NATO member,
by the dawn of the 1960s the Swiss Federal
Council clearly recognized who the enemy was,
and that was communism.
A year before the parliament in Bern enacted
the Federal law, the FOCP was given a council
of ten experts to figure out how to build
bunkers that would protect people not only
from a nuclear blast but also from the resulting
radiation.
Yes, no one actually knew how to make one.
At the time, the only theoretical compendium
available in the West about the atomic bomb
was the book The Effects of Nuclear Weapons
written by physicist Samuel Glasstone, published
by the U.S. government in 1957, and based
on experiments conducted by the Pentagon in
Nevada and the Bikini Atoll.
In July 1963, the Swiss FOCP's board of experts
invited a number of U.S. and West German researchers
to the Swiss Federal Institute of Technology
in Zurich to design in cooperation with Washington
a working prototype of a fallout bunker.
There and then, the conference turned out
to be a failure.
Yet in October, the Swiss parliament would
still pass the Federal Act on Civil Defense
Construction.
This wasn’t a reckless move.
In fact, during the Zurich conference, the
director of the Swiss Federal Institute of
Technology, military engineer Ernst Basler,
came into contact with the Naval Radiological
Defense Laboratory in San Francisco, Stanford
University and MIT in Cambridge.
Thanks to these connections, between 1964
and 1970, dozens of Swiss scientists traveled
to the United States, gained access to their
technologies and, once back home, contributed
their knowledge to what we might call a veritable
shelter boom.
Within just six years, the number of private
fallout bunkers in Switzerland reached one
hundred thousand, capable of protecting about
50 percent of the population.
An astonishing achievement, considering that
the United States itself has never been able
to implement a structural program to spread
the underground with bunkers.
It may seem like nonsense to you, but the
success and speed of the Swiss shelters lies...in
not having conducted experiments.
Basler and the FOCP's board of experts had
to act quickly to fulfill the provisions of
the 1963 Construction Act, while trying to
keep costs down.
With a world war considered imminent, there
was no time for testing.
So, scientists put together all the data they
had collected on the effects of a nuclear
explosion to design cost-benefit optimal countermeasures.
Plants, walls, doors, floors, and ventilation
systems were designed according to the following
calculation: with an estimated investment
of 1.000 Swiss francs per person, Switzerland
could have bunkers capable of saving from
an atomic detonation 90 percent of all those
who took shelter in them.
The culmination of bunkering occurred starting
in 1971, when the Federal Act on Civil Protection
was extended to all settlements.
Each private shelter would be 70 percent publicly
funded.
If one were to point to the greatest work
of the entire fortification process in the
Swiss Confederation, one couldn’t fail to
mention The Sonnenberg Tunnel.
Opened in 1976 in Lucerne, hidden underneath
a playground, one of the world's largest civilian
bunkers cost about 40 million francs, was
designed to extend along three kilometers
of tunnels located on the highway linking
Basel to Lugano, and to accommodate about
20 thousand people.
The Bunker is a seven-story building stretching
downwards, and in the minds of the FOCP would
have required about 700 employees to run its
beds, command station, hospital, kitchen,
laundry and prison.
In short, a real Vault built by Vault tec.
It's just too bad that, right now, it’s
not as massive as planned.
In 1987, a year after the Chernobyl accident,
the authorities conducted a general test to
evaluate the operation of the Cavern, and
realized the infeasibility of the initial
plan.
In fact, it would never have been possible
to cram such a large number of human beings
into such a small space.
In addition, getting beds through inside narrow
corridors would have been a difficult task,
on par with handling telecommunications in
the absence of radio contact.
Last but not least, some of the doors that
were supposed to seal the tunnels seemed to
encounter problems in closing.
In 2006, the housing capacity of the Sonnenberg
Bunker was downsized, and it’s estimated
that it can currently accommodate two thousand
people in case of need.
There is another problem, however.
According to guide Zora Schelbert, this bunker
can certainly come in handy in case of natural
disasters such as landslides or earthquakes,
but not in case of a nuclear explosion.
After all, the shelter is meant to serve as
a base of support for only a few weeks.
A time frame too short for the radiation,
outside, to thin out.
At present, the main function performed by
the Tunnel is as a tourist attraction, and
in recent decades hundreds of unused bunkers,
some dating back to the 1940s, have been converted
into museums, architectural works, warehouses,
mushroom farms, hotels and data centers, and
even migrant shelters.
An inauspicious end, you might say, but certainly
dictated by the changing geopolitical environment.
Although between 1982 and 1983 the Swiss government
had invested $28 per capita in the defense
sector, ten more than the entire Soviet Union,
the threats of the Cold War, and with it the
fear of atomic attack, soon vanished.
From 1989, the rate of shelter construction
declined but not the debate over the nation's
total defense.
During the 1980s, the Swiss parliament began
to show its first doubts about fortifying
the country, and a pacifist ideology, critical
of the militaristic policies pursued by the
federal government in previous decades, became
prevalent among the intellectuals of the time.
Swiss journalist Jean-Gabriel Zufferey summed
them up in 1989 with the term "hedgehog syndrome."
Then the 1990s passed, and the attack on the
Twin Towers on September 11, 2001 generated
tremendous insecurity throughout the West.
When, in 2005, Congressman Pierre Kohler proposed
to abolish the requirement to build bunkers
adjacent to private homes to avoid unnecessarily
increasing the cost of real estate, the Federal
Council decided that the shelters were still
useful in defending the population from terrorist
attacks.
The issue was reignited in March 2011, following
the Fukushima nuclear disaster.
However, during this time, Swiss authorities
have gradually relaxed the penalties for violating
the Federal Law on Civil Protection.
According to a new regulation that came into
effect in 2012 and was confirmed in 2022,
only buildings with 38 or more rooms will
have to have a fallout shelter.
If it’s impossible for technical reasons
to build one, an annual replacement fee of
800 Swiss francs, about 895 dollars at today's
exchange rate, will have to be paid to the
state.
The same fee is paid by all other property
owners who don’t want to make a home shelter,
to guarantee them a place in a public bunker.
The latter, however, must be located in the
proximity of homes, that is, a distance that
can be walked in half an hour.
According to current regulations, a bunker
must be built according to the technical instructions
issued by the Federal Department of Defense
in 2017, which indicate materials, measures
and maintenance activities to be followed
for every facility built within the structures,
from security doors to kitchens, from ventilation
and communication systems to toilets and light
bulbs.
For the past year, Russia's invasion of Ukraine
and the feared use of tactical nuclear weapons
has again alarmed Bern and the cantons.
According to Stephen Herzog, a nuclear weapons
expert working at the Swiss Federal Institute
of Technology in Zurich, Switzerland is currently
the country best prepared for a possible atomic
conflict, not only because of the 370.000
bunkers scattered throughout its territory,
but also because of the excellent level of
nuclear and radiological protection provided
by them.
The whole of Switzerland, then, is covered
by more than 7.000 sirens, which are also
activated in case of more localized disasters,
such as fires or floods.
Finally, the Alert Swiss app, available since
2019, informs the population about current
alerts, and was also functional during the
Covid-19 pandemic.
In short, it would be fair to say that, somehow,
the strategy of Redoubt envisioned in the
late 1800s has survived to the present day.
Of course, it has changed guises: it has become
the armor of a small country squeezed between
the Alps, but diplomatically and economically
at the pinnacle of the international order.
Such preparation for any kind of catastrophe
is admirable, as well as unmatched, at present,
for any other state on the face of the Earth.
Sweden and Finland, second and third in class
in the bunker league, have facilities that
can save "only" 70 and 62 percent of their
residents, respectively.
Some cantons, such as Grisons and Glarus would
be able to shelter 140% of their population.
This is the result of the federal government's
investment of about $12 billion, diluted over
60 years.
All this, of course, doesn’t mean that the
world's most anti-atomic nation is safe from
any apocalyptic scenario.
Again according to Stephen Herzog, in the
event of a nuclear escalation of the Ukrainian
conflict, there are so many variables at play
including weather conditions, explosive yield
of weapons, and altitude of detonations that
it’s impossible to determine with certainty
whether the distance to the war zone and the
network of shelters can protect the Swiss
people 100 percent.
But then, is it really possible to survive
nuclear armageddon?
And once the world we are used to living in
is devastated, what will be left of us?
One thing is certain, those who come out to
see the stars again had better have power
armor with them, you can’t know what threats
might be lurking outside the vault.
Well and we're done for today, I thank you
all for your attention and we’ll see you
in the next video.
Ciao!